bonjour laurent wauquiez bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
des républicains vous êtes le président
de la grande région auvergne et rhône
alpes
il va y avoir ce moment où emmanuel
macron va s'exprimer c'est peut-être
demain c'est peut-être après demain en
tout cas c'est dans les tout prochains
jours
il devrait faire ses propres
propositions pour sortir du grand débat
mais après la question elle est très
simple et tout à fait évidente qu'est ce
que vous en attendez vous le savez nous
on s'est engagé dans ce débat parce
qu'on a considéré que c'était notre
responsabilité de contribuer à amener du
calme
vous me demandez qu'est ce que j'en
attends ce que j'en attends c'est que
enfin les paroles soient suivies d'actes
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là je
pense pas ou fait que le débat a duré
des longs mois parfois des trop longs
mois il a été trop long pour vous ce
grand débat il est temps en tout cas il
est en en sortant tout cas je pense
qu'il est temps d'en sortir mais c'est
pas un sac ce que je pense
ce à quoi je pense c'est que si on
regarde ce qui s'est passé depuis deux
ans bien souvent on a eu des paroles
assez tonitruante parfois des
rodomontades et que quand on regarde à
l'arrivée ce qui avait ça souvent été
pas grand chose nous a dit par exemple
qui aurait une révolution copernicienne
sur le code du travail
la réalité c'est qu'il ya quasiment rien
qui a changé quand vous interrogez ceux
qui veulent embaucher
le président de la république
souvenez-vous nous avait expliqué que
dans le domaine du social on gaspille un
pognon de dingue
nous lui avons fait la proposition de
dire bah expérimentons le fait qu'en
contrepartie du rsa en puisse mettre des
heures de travail pas de réponse encore
très récemment le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur castaner nous dit
les ong sont les complices des passeurs
et à peine quelques jours après on
apprend que la france s'apprête à
prendre une des migrants qui sont
arrivés précisément son gâteau d'une ong
si haye et donc qu'est ce que je veux
dire ce que vous voulez dire qu'il ya un
décalage entre ce qu'il ce que je vais
vous citer un seul membre de phrase
excès auxquels finalement vous êtes
plutôt d'accord quand c'est une pensée
lane ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que j'ai le sentiment que depuis deux
ans ça a été très fort dans les mots est
plutôt faible dans les actes et que s'il
ya un tournant à prendre ses enfants
s'attaquer au sol sujet central des
français qui a été totalement esquivé
depuis deux ans une baisse durable des
impôts pour tous les français vous allez
vous allez vous faire vous proposions
mais je m'arrête juste à l'instant sur
ce que vous venez de dire en si je
comprends bien au fond quand ils
s'expriment et quand il est un peu cache
ben vous êtes plutôt d'accord avec lui
mais après vous constatez qu a pas grand
chose qui se passe mais vous êtes plutôt
d'accord avec les idées quoi le
sentiment qu'on a depuis deux ans c'est
que parfois quand on écoute on se dit il
ya peut-être des choses sur lesquelles
on pourrait travailler ensemble et qu
ensuite quand on regarde les actes y'a
plus rien regardons par exemple le sujet
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai une baisse
durable des impôts vous vous proposez un
je reviens juste aux propositions que
vous avez commencé à formuler cette
semaine vous proposait notamment une
baisse de 10% de l'impôt sur le revenu
pour tous c'est à dire toutes les
tranches vous me permettez de s'arrêter
deux secondes
regardez déjà l'endroit où vous allez
comment voulez vous que la baisse
d'impôts soit durable si on commence pas
d'abord par poser la question de comment
baisse la dépense publique si demain ou
après-demain dans les propositions du
président de la république il n'y a rien
qui est mis sur comment on finance alors
tous les français seront que c'est un
jeu du donc vous avant d'arriver à cette
baisse de 10% qui est votre objectif
vous allez nous expliquer du coup
comment vous baisser la dépense commencé
par baisser pour pouvoir j'ai bien sûr
je vous l'avais dit je préside une
grande région la région vers le rhône
alpes en trois ans on a fait de très
gros efforts pour baisser les dépenses
de fonctionnement et on est une des
régions de france qui a le plus baissé
ses dépenses de fonctionnement et c'est
parce qu'on a fait sans qu'ensuite on a
pu baisser et quasiment aucune région de
la fait les taxes dans notre région mais
vous vous êtes bien d'accord que c'est
pas la même échelle
madame pauline de madame c'est beaucoup
trop facile de dire ça si tout le monde
fait cet effort alors on peut y arriver
si on a un président de la république
qui comme il l'a fait dans l'entrée dans
le débat lâche 10 milliards d'euros
comme ça sur des primes gouvernementales
totalement non financé ce qu'il a fait
en décembre
vous vous souvenez que sur ce qu'il a
lâché même pas 10% était financé les
français sont pas stupides ils
comprennent très bien comment ça va
finir ça va finir comme en bas comme on
a fait des trous on reprendra à nouveau
dans la rue vous
trouver où cet argent vous le savez on
s'est engagé sur un plan d'économies de
20 milliards d'euros premier exemple
très simple on propose d'augmenter le
temps de travail dans la fonction
publique et de faire en sorte que ce
travail cette augmentation la soit
compensée en partie par des primes au
mérite pour ceux qui sont engagés élargi
un exemple vous fait économiser beaucoup
mais c'est colossal
est-ce que vous rendez compte que en
moyenne et les derniers rapports l'ont
montré on n'est même pas 35 heures dans
bien des compartiments de la fonction
publique dans ma région quand je suis
arrivé on était à moins de 35 heures
j'ai passé tout le monde à 35 ha on a
mis des primes au mérite et du conte à
inciter les gens
deuxième exemple est très bien fait
notamment dans dans les analyses qui ont
été faits par l'ifrap on a une
complexité administrative en france qui
est sans aucun même millefeuille
complexe oui répondent en mai mais même
par exemple sur la gestion des
administrations par exemple juste faire
fonctionner notre système de prestations
sociales
je parle même pas du niveau coûte 20 à
30% plus cher qu'en allemagne ce qui
veut dire que si enfin on ouvrait un peu
les choses si on simplifiait si on avait
le courage de s'attaquer à la
bureaucratie pas aux services publics à
la bureaucratie on peut y arriver
donc première session d'épreuves pardon
mais là ça faisait partie des promesses
des manuels marque et l'avait promis de
simplifier considérablement vous dit
exactement ce que je vous disais au
début beaucoup de discours et revient
même à quoi vous vous seriez différents
mais tout simplement clair c'est que si
on vous croit on s'est déjà fait avoir
une fois par ce discours là pourquoi ne
serait pas avoir par votre discours à
vous j'aime bien cette question et je
vais vous dire pourquoi c'est
précisément pour ça que je vous donne
l'exemple de ce que je fais dans ma
région
parce que vous pouvez vérifier et que
tous ceux qui m'écoutent peuvent dire
très bien le discours mais est ce que il
le fait dans ses responsabilités oui et
c'est ce à quoi je m'astreins je
souhaite que les républicains cette
nouvelle droite qu'on veut construire
s'astreignent systématiquement à ce que
dans les responsabilités qui sont les
nôtres on s'applique ce qu'on propose
maintenant je voudrais si vous me le
permettez qu'on passe à la deuxième
condition de la sortie du grand débat
d'abord nadine besse durable si on veut
une baisse du reste durable des dépenses
en a il faut créer une baisse de la
dépense
ok la deuxième question c'est tous les
français pourquoi je vous dis ça je
regarde ce que vous proposez c'est
effectivement cette baisse de 2 de
l'impôt sur le revenu pour tous les
français pas seulement pour les riches
les pauvres les moyens exactement que
tout le monde et sa feuille d'impôts qui
baissent de 10%
prenons
exemple de ce que en ce moment est agité
par le gouvernement et qui pourrait être
une des feuilles de sortie on nous dit
on va baisser l'impôt sur le revenu mais
seulement pour une partie des français
avec un discours qui honnêtement quand
on prend un peu de sang est surréaliste
on nous dit on va baisser uniquement par
exemple avec une tranche plus basse pour
ceux qui sont entre 1700 et 1800 euros
mais stop stop avec ça vous êtes à 1750
euros c'est bon vous êtes à 1900 c'est
pas pour voulais pas de ça et vous
voulez que non pourquoi
parce qu'en france le problème c'est pas
seulement niveau d'impôts c'est que les
impôts sont concentrés sur les mêmes et
les mêmes c'est qui c'est ceux qui sont
au milieu c'est les classes moyennes et
donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est une baisse
de l'impôt sur le revenu pour tout le
monde
simple clair pas d' usine à gaz - 10 %
pour tous ceux qui payent l'impôt sur le
revenu laurent wauquiez est ce que vous
avez le sentiment que la crise des
gilets jaunes avec derrière nous juste
un deuxième point quand même parce que
il ya deux propositions et après j'y
reviendrai la deuxième c'est la
revalorisation des retraités et là c'est
le même ce sera a priori vous êtes tous
d'accord mais non par la république en
marino n'a fait partie des propositions
y compris du parti la république en
marché de ce nom ça se gagne
soyez précise qu'est ce qu'ils proposent
revalorisation uniquement des petites
retraites au niveau de l'inflation
et là encore vous vous dites pour tous
et qu'est ce qu'ils appellent petites
retraites ils disent
un couple de retraités qui a deux mille
euros c'est les riches et l'ont confié
pas pour eux c'est inacceptable la
retraite c'est pas une prestation c'est
par un minima social la retraite c'est
pas un privilège
la retraite c'est le fruit d'une vie de
travail dans un pays comme la france on
n'est pas capable de garantir que les
retraites évolué au moins au niveau de
l'inflation
non et le dernier point ça nous rappelle
à l'origine de la crise ça permettra de
répondre à votre question c'est la
question du carburant
est-ce que la fiscalité sur le carburant
était annulé non est ce que les hausses
qui ont été décidées qui ont précipité
la crise sur les jets les ondes ont été
effacés non ils ont arrêté d augmenter
mais vous voudriez carrément qu'il
revienne sur ce qu'ils ont décidé en
2018 en 2018 des nouvelles hausses de
taxes ont été décidées par le
gouvernement bien plus violente est bien
plus dur que tout ce qui avait été prévu
avant ça aboutit à la hausse des
carburants et on est d'ailleurs un train
de constater une nouvelle hausse est
donc
vous prenez nos propositions qu'est ce
que c'est baisse durable des impôts pour
tous les français financée par des
économies sur la dépense publique et je
ne veux pas qu'on sorte avec des seuils
à nouveau on s'occupe de certains et on
laisse deux fois c'est très clair pour
le coup c'est très clair vos trois
propositions elles sont elles sont
précises mais avec la question je me
pose en vous écoutant vous dites nous
mais est ce que véritablement vous
parlez au nom du nous vous parlez pour
qui ce que je vous dis c'est
l'aboutissement de six mois de travail
dans notre famille politique
bah oui mais moi je vous trouve assez
seul quand je regarde ne serait ce que
dans la presse ce matin
je vois que françois baroin a fait sa
propre interviews et françois baroin il
la commence cette interview dix ans
selon moi je le cite entre guillemets et
idy même il dit selon moi il dit de mon
point de vue il le dit aussi à plusieurs
reprises pareil valérie pécresse qui
était là la semaine dernière elle elle a
sa propre idée sa propre idée à elle
c'est la baisse de la tva sur les
transports bruno retailleau cette
semaine disait que lui la priorité
c'était le référendum sur l'immigration
edis tous moi je mets pardon madame
pauline de malherbe que dans une famille
politique c'est de l'émulation que les
gens sera la nomination c'est chacun
dans son coin
pas du tout là ce que je vous dis moi je
suis président de notre famille j'ai la
responsabilité notre collectif et donc
quand moi je vous parle c'est pas
uniquement laurent wauquiez et celles
non c'est je fais les jusqu'au bout ces
propositions ont été validées par notre
bureau politique elles sont le fruit du
travail de tout le travail qui a été
fait par des dizaines de parlementaires
autour de guillaume larrivé vous avez
dernièrement des sénateurs des députés
qui sont gagnés avec vos documents et
qui ont travaillé autour de ses
propositions
par exemple le plan d'économies de la
dépense publique a été fait avec eric
woerth
le président de la commission des
finances on a travaillé christian jacob
et bruno retailleau et précisément ce
que j'essaye de mais alors comment vous
expliquez que malgré tout on a un peu le
sentiment mais vraiment je dirais que
une forme même d'étonnement c'est que
les est une partie est un parti où
traditionnellement à droite il ya
toujours un chef il ya un ordre
il ya une organisation ce n'était pas le
cas à gauche n'était pas le cas à gauche
mais ce qui était votre cave ou
vêtements ça devient soyons à ce point
aussi selon moi ça y est
vu chacun a son petit tunnel quoi soyons
un petit peu honnête vous n'allez pas me
dire qu'au cours des dernières années
vous avez sincèrement une impression que
la droite a donné l'image mais l'apathie
filiale corpus de la north d'accord moi
ce que j'essaye de faire c'est
précisément de refaire prendre ce sens
du rassemblement un point serait ce que
vous n'êtes pas en train de vous faire
avoir mais pas du tout ce que j'essaye
de vous dire qui est très simple dans
une équipe de foot que faisait des
talents qui s'expriment c'est pas un
problème la seule chaussée qui a une
feuille de match est donc dans toutes
les propositions que vous mettez moi ce
qui me choquerait sait si j'avais des
républicains qui venaient en disant
banon on oublie le dépense publique et
ont fait du déficit pour financer les
baisses d'impôts ça ce serait totalement
contraire qu en revanche françois baroin
nous disent moi je pense que sur la csg
ya quelque chose afin est ce que ça me
choque non c'est pas la ligne de notre
famille politique c'est pas le travail
collectif qui a été mis en place mais
qui est un peu de stimulation d'idées ça
ne m'a jamais gêné à une condition dans
la même direction
est ce que j'ai essayé de refaire c'est
une famille qui travaille dans la même
direction
je laisse s'exprimer les talents parce
que je ne veux pas les brides et je
considère que ça fait partie de
l'énergie de la création de façon si
bien sûr que j brand dire d'arrêter mais
je pourrais sur votre plateau vous dire
c'est grotesque il ferait mieux tous
d'être embrigadés dans la même ligne etc
c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse à une
condition tout le monde va dans la même
direction et moi ma responsabilité c'est
ça c'est le collectif et c'est ce que
j'ai aussi contribuer à ramener
regardez ce que c'était ya encore six ou
dix mois aujourd'hui à l'image d'une
droite qui travaille dans la même ligne
chacun avec sa sensibilité chacun avec
sa façon de le dire mais dans la même et
on va revenir notamment sur les
européennes dans un instant avec janick
halimi je voudrais vous entendre aussi
surprise des gilet jaune je vous posais
la question est ce que est ce que pour
vous cette crise des gilet jaune elle
est derrière nous est ce que c'est fini
est-ce que les magnifiques en aura plus
est ce que le gouvernement a repris
contrôlant quelle que soit la réponse
malheureusement la vie hier à nouveau
moins de violence vous rendez compte
suse vous vous rendez compte ce qu'on
est en train de dire c'est pas si grave
on est juste au 22e week end
22e week-end et vous avez à nouveau ces
images de casseurs de gens qui détruit
du mobilier urbain qui brûlent des
voitures et qui s'attaquent aux forces
de l'ordre
la réalité c'est qu'on assiste un échec
majeur de l'autorité dans ce pays est ce
que je regrette c'est que le
gouvernement n'en ai pas pris la mesure
assez tôt
une responsabilité dans ce qui s'est
passé nous désole ses fins dès le 4
décembre on avait plaidé en mettant des
propositions sur la table pour que l'on
utilise les leviers de l'état d'urgence
ils nous ont pas écoutés les sénateurs
républicains avaient travaillé sur la
loi sur les casseurs qu'est ce qu'on
constate ce qu'on a constaté ce samedi
c'est que la loi sur les casseurs ça n'a
pas marché
pourquoi parce qu'elle a été vidé de sa
substance par la censure du conseil
constitutionnel mais ça c'est pas un peu
du moment j'ai envie de dire vous auriez
eu la même censure vous trouvez normal
que le président de la république
lui-même et affaiblit la loi on l'a
déférents conseil constitutionnel il
aurait bien que ce n'était pas une
preuve au contraire de se dire bon ben
voila moi je je vais au devant du
conseil constitionnel je n'ai rien à
cacher je c'était pour moi et je le
regrette
le sentiment d'un président de la
république n'était pas convaincu par ce
qu'ils faisaient et c'est à l'image
malheureusement de ce qu'ils ont fait
sur ces question d'autorité
ça a manqué d'autorité interdite voilà
il tergiverse y tout en même temps
d'accord et quand on fait tout en même
temps de fait rien alors si on veut en
sortir parce que je veux toujours que
nous on s'astreignent à mettre des
propositions est dans quelque chose de
constructif
nous sommes convaincus qu'il faut mettre
en place des peines planchers pour ceux
qui attaquent nos forces de l'ordre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que si jamais vous en prenez aux
gendarmes aux policiers aux gardiens de
prison à nos douaniers il faut qu'ils
aient des peines exemplaires minimale
parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut que les
français le sachent dont ceux qui ont
été arrêtés
80% de ceux des casseurs qui ont été
arrêtés ont été purement et simplement
relâché dans la nature ça c'est pas
possible
et donc il faut reconquérir le terrain
perdu en terme d'autorité
c'est pour ça que ce qu'on propose c'est
ce système de peines plancher qui permet
de s'assurer que quelqu'un qui sont
prend un gendarme un policier
bah il est condamné sinon ça peut pas
marcher sqv quand même sentiment que ce
grand débat a été utile juste pardonnez
moi je voudrais aller jusqu'au bout de
cette question de l'autorité c'est pas
juste la question des casseurs se sait
pas si vous avez regardé les derniers
chiffres mais on est en train d'assister
à une très forte montée de l'insécurité
et de la violence dans notre pays qui
parfois d'ailleurs s'incarne dans des
faits divers qui frappe les esprits
comme c'est un cette professeure de
seine-saint-denis attaqué dans sa salle
de classe
ma crainte c'est que le gouvernement
s'enferme dans un grand retour de
l'idéologie portait à l'époque de par
christian
bien et qu'on est un peu ce retour d'une
politique extrêmement laxiste sur le
plan judiciaire tant ils sont pas
tellement d'accord philosophie non bah
oui mais regardez les derniers propos de
la garde des sceaux qu'est ce qu'elle
nous dit elodie faut faire de la
régulation carcéral ça c'est un joli mot
mais grand quoi mais qui englobe une
réalité très simple c'est le laxisme
judiciaire
c'est à dire que ceux qui sont condamnés
à des peines de prison ne doivent pas
aller en prison
c'est les propos de la garde des sceaux
quand elle dit que quelqu'un condamné à
six mois de prison ne doit pas aller en
prison
elle se trompe selon dont on a besoin
c'est pas leur tour de ski et l approche
de madame taubira
ce dont on a besoin c'est un retour de
fermeté pour combattre cette montée
forte de la violence dans le pays
ça y est ils montent et forte de la
violence dans le pays
enfin vous avez à dire en dehors là pour
le coup on parle puis on parle pas de
gilet jaune a bien compris que là vous
parliez d'une violence partout dans les
divers dons mais vous n'avez pas vu les
derniers chiffres les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur en un an
augmentation de près de 15% des vols
augmentation de plus de 10 % des
homicides augmentation de plus de 10%
des coups et blessures
ce sont des chiffres qu'on n'a jamais
vus et le chat vous et pour vous c'est
un domaine sur lequel donc le
gouvernement ne tient pas bah quand vous
avez un ministre de l'intérieur qui à
mon avis n'a pas le profil pour
restaurer les questions de sécurité
quand vous avez une garde des sceaux qui
explique qu' on va faire de la
régulation carcéral au lieu de
construire des places de prison
supplémentaires
je crains qu'on sous estime et que ce
soit la même chose estimation qui a eu
lieu pour reprendre la main sur les
casseurs est la même que je ne voudrais
pas voir se reproduire pour faire face à
la montée de la violence
je voudrais qu'on parle des européennes
et on va courir tout de suite janyk
halimi du parisien aujourd'hui en france
[Musique]
bonjour générique bonjour laurent
wauquiez bonjour avant d'abord les
européennes je voudrais juste quand même
m'arrêter un instant sur vous vous
laurent wauquiez voilà environ un an et
demi que vous êtes à la présidence des
républicains et on a l'impression que
vous n'arrivez pas à faire consensus
autour de vous apolline de mahler parlé
tout à l'heure de la polyphonie que vous
avez justifié au sein de votre parti
mais vous on vous fait un double
reproche à la fois de président et en
solitaire est à la fois de ne pas
entraîner de ne pas vraiment chez fait
est ce que au bout d'un an et demi de
présidence
vous faites votre mea culpa vous estimez
que vous avez fait quelques erreurs
madame halimi vous me fait sourire parce
que si précisément on fait sans doute
les deux reproches soit à la fois trop
chez fait de passer chez fait c'est
peut-être sans doute que l'on a fini par
trouver une bonne ligne de travail
on va discuter on réside en solo c'est
pas trop chez fait un c'est en solo
militaire suite malgré six un
commentaire fait par des journalistes du
monde
certes qui est un journal qui nous
soutient beaucoup j'ai aucun reproche à
leur faire ils font leur travail
si d'ailleurs vous citez avec précision
l'article et site des personnalités
comme eric ciotti qui disent au
contraire qu'il ya un très bon travail
en commun qui s'est installée la réalité
c'est quoi prenez juste un peu
l'historique voyez d'où on vient
regardez la façon dont la droite ait
explosé en face on pose donc je les
récupère après cette présidentielle qui
était catastrophique et continue à
exploser depuis que vous êtes à la
présidence il ya des gens comme monsieur
à farah monsieur juppé qui ont pris pour
le moins leur distance et oui et j'ai
fait mise
j'ai considéré que c'était indispensable
ah bon parce que y'a un moment où la
clarté et est indispensable mais est un
peu l'honnêteté aussi de regarder ce qui
s'est passé
quelle est la liste qui progresse le
plus dans les pronostics des européennes
depuis un mois et demi laquelle passe
hélas vote pour le rafale à l'esprit
celle des républiques hals dirigée par
françois xavier bellamy bien sûr et
c'est un choix que j'ai souhaité et je
voudrais vous l'expliquer j'ai pas voulu
restaurer les erreurs du passé et j'ai
assumé de dire oui on va passer par une
phase qui est une phase de turbulences
mais pour faire émerger des nouveaux
visages pour faire en sorte que la
droite qu'on construise réfléchissent
sur le passé ce qu'on a réussi ce qu'on
pas réussi pour s'appuyer sur des
convictions qui soit forte et claire
parce que ça m'a pas échappé comme avoue
bien sûr je vais pas venir sur ce
plateau en faisant semblant que dans le
prolongement de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron il ya eu un grand tumulte un
grand trouble d esprit que parfois et ça
m'a choquée moi aussi des gens qui
disaient une chose se sont mis à dire
linverse parce qu'on leur avait proposé
un poste que quelqu'un comme bruno le
maire qui était avant dans notre famille
politique qui avait fait campagne à la
primaire en proposant la baisse de la
csg parce qu'on lui a proposé de prendre
une responsabilité à bercy s'est mis
tout d'un coup à faire exactement
inverse
ouais enfin que sa jupe n est pas allé
au gouvernement avec edouard philippe
non il est au conseil constitutionnel ah
bon et donc mais mais mais mais juste
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là madame
aline ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que on a commencé à reconstruire pas
justement tous ensemble on a une parole
de la droite qui est à nouveau identifié
qui un discours clair sur l'autorité qui
est un discours clair sur dire nous
c'est les baisses de dépenses publiques
et les baisses d'impôts qui est un
discours clair aussi contre l'islamisme
sujet sur lequel le président de la
république est beaucoup trop naïf
cette parole on voit qu'elle est en
train de se reconstruire on monte dans
les sondages toutes les personnalités et
moi qui ai la responsabilité de notre
famille évidemment françois-xavier
belhani notre liste de droite qui
progresse et ça ça me fait plaisir
d'accord parce que je sens avec eux par
rapport à il ya six mois et vous le
reconnaissez vous même est quelque chose
qui a changé très dynamique qui est en
train de s'installer donc pas de mea
culpa de votre part pas de nom mais
j'entends bien vous êtes plutôt
satisfait du travail que vous faites de
la ballerine me on fait tous des erreurs
tout le monde mais ce qui me plaît c'est
quoi c'est que dans cette élection
européenne
la liste qui a une dynamique et c'est
celle des républicains la liste kane
dynamique c'est celle des républicains
en justice un celi c'est une partiede
barnes est en train de se reconstruire
aussi mort que vous partiez de vous
partiez de bas par rapport à votre socle
actuel jacques hayé avons effectivement
vous avez fait un choix c'est important
ma faim vous partiez dans les sondages
de 6 à 7% vous êtes maintenant entre 13
et 15 est quand même loin des 20% 10 à 5
ans et des 30% digne à dire je vais et
je vais vous dire quelque chose
je suis convaincu qu'on va encore
progresser quels objectifs
je joue pas au loto quand je fais donc
bien sûr non mais je parle en tant
qu'homme d'état que vous êtes
je voudrais juste vous expliquer
pourquoi j'en suis convaincu parce que
je pense que cette remontée traduit
quelque chose de beaucoup plus profond
juste qu'une question de politicienne de
savoir où en sont les républicains
qu'est ce que ce n'est pas françois
xavier bellamy qui a une caution
personnelle qui plaît peut-être plus que
vous qui entraîne peut-être plus que
l'avant train madame halimi essayer
d'opposer les gens les uns aux autres ça
n'a pas de sens je me suis battu parfois
seul contre tous le monde pour faire en
sorte que françois-xavier bellamy soit
choisi je les fais parfois contre bien
des voix qui se sont exprimées dans ma
famille politique et qui n'ont voulait
gérard larcher par exemple président du
sénat oui et je suis d'ailleurs très
heureux puisque gérard lyncher sera à
nos côtés mardi prochain à nîmes pour le
lancement de notre campagne et pour
apporter tout son soutien
françois-xavier bel ami dont il a eu
d'ailleurs
et cette honnêteté intellectuelle
l'honore le mérite de reconnaître bah
oui c'était le bon choix est et ce qu'il
fallait un temps il sera avec vous ce
n'était pas forcément gagné
bien sûr ce qui est madame apolline de
manière encore une façon de vous
répondre
bédard qui a quelque chose qui
s'installe mais je voudrais pardon je
voudrais juste qu'on se pose que c'est
bon parfois aussi de prendre un petit
peu un moment pour comprendre ce qui se
passe pourquoi est-ce qu'à mon avis les
choses ont bougé parce que je suis
convaincu que les français ne veulent
pas être prisonnier de la réédition du
second tour de la présidentielle et que
au fond ils n'ont pas envie qu'on leur
impose ce choix dans lequel il ne
pourrait choisir que entre d'une part le
chaos de marine le pen et d'autre part
les déceptions des manuels macron
pourquoi est ce que notre liste a autant
progressé parce que les français se sont
dit les républicains ont reconstruit ils
ont appris il amène une nouvelle droite
ils se sont rassemblés ils ont un
programme sur les européennes qui est
clair à ce jour nous sommes la seule
famille politique avoir mis son
programme pour les européennes sur la
table et au fond qu'est ce qu'on cherche
à faire
on cherche à dire aux français pour les
européennes vous avez le choix vous
n'êtes pas condamné entre d'un côté le
chaos de marine le pen et de l'autre
côté la déception des manuels macron
vous avez le choix et c'est ce pour quoi
on se bat et je suis convaincu que les
français ne veulent pas au fond
être emprisonné qu'on leur dicte ce
qu'ils ont à faire lors d'une élection
dont j'aimerais bien fait mais sans une
alternative que vous jugé crédible mais
justement sur haut lieu on s'ajuste que
les français en tout cas dans les
sondages par s accordent plus en plus de
crédit parce qu'il faut le reconnaître
vous êtes quand même loin du duo de tête
qui reste tout de même le rassemblement
national et où la république en marche
tout de même il faut le il faut le
rappeler mais sur votre programme vous
en parliez vous même vous parlez
beaucoup de l'islamisation de la société
des racines judéo-chrétiennes
gréco-latine également et des lumières
merci de de l'europe d'un autre côté
peut-être en ce moment-même marine le
pen est en train d'annoncer quasiment
officiellement le fait que son parti
sort de son positionnement anti union
européenne donc frais xi et même anti
zone euro qu'elles sont finalement les
différences entre vous entre le
programme des républicains et celui du
rassemblement national et j'ai presque
envie de dire que le vote est peut-être
encore plus à droite en termes culturels
voire idéologique que celui de marine le
pen aujourd'hui en tout cas sûrement sur
la nécessité de réaffirmer nos valeurs
ce qui est l'identité française et
l'identité européennes
la volonté de la transmettre de lutter
contre l'islamisme là dessus will not
least est sûrement la plus déterminée et
y compris j'y reviendrai sur la question
de la protection des frontières
mais vous m'interrogez sur ou en est le
programme du front national de marine le
pen
l'enfant regarde exactement ce qu'elle
dit
regardez les reniements qui sont
dernière qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit par
exemple sur l'euro et nous dînons
abandonner l'euro n'est plus notre
première priorité
souvenez vous il ya un an et demi de ce
qu'elle disait 70% de mon programme est
impossible à réaliser s'il n'y a pas la
sortie de l'euro alors tactiquement elle
ne parle plus de la sortie l'euro mais
qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit je veux
que nous retrouvions notre souveraineté
monétaire
mais enfin c'est prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles
parce que retrouver sa souveraineté
monétaire ça veut dire quoi
si ce n'est des construire leur aux
puits
la base même de l'euro c'est accepter
qu'on perde une partie de notre
souveraineté monétaire en ayant en
échange plus de protection une monnaie
plus forte et donc quand elle dit on va
pas déconstruire l'euro mais on va
retrouvé notre souveraineté monétaire
ça veut dire une seule chose ça veut
dire déconstruire euros deuxième exemple
breakes site
vous avez quand même très vite mais nous
aux briques si on parle vous avez tous
bien compris que le break cité le modèle
de marine le pen
personne n'a oublié ici autour de la
table qui au lendemain du vote du bric
site
elle a dit c'est une victoire pour la
liberté et donc la liste de marine le
pen et c'est son droit c'est une liste
qui propose de déconstruire l'europe
telle qu'elle évoque donc ce qu'elle dit
aujourd'hui en revenant sur cette
proposition pour vous de toute façon
c'est en contradiction avec le coeur
même du coup de sonde exalead oman mais
je voudrais juste un dernier missile
vrai qu'on puise la question de la
protection des frontières
elle permet de bien comprendre ce que
nous nous offrons dans ce débat
protection des frontières européennes
face à la question de l'immigration
vous avez d'un côté la proposition de
marine le pen il faut pas de défense
européenne des frontières
c'est une folie si on ne protège pas nos
frontière espagnole italienne ou grecque
la réalité c'est que ceux qui rentrent
arrive ensuite chez nous vous avez de
l'autre côté les propositions des
manuels macron qui disent banon il faut
pas que les états nationaux puis choisir
qui rentrent chez eux c'est une folie
aussi nous ce qu'on propose c'est une
double protection des frontières des
garde-côtes européen pour nous protéger
et la possibilité pour chaque état de
choisir qui rentre ou non sur son
territoire et ça vous avez avec ça la
très claire différence de notre liste
d'un côté la déconstruction de l'europe
de l'autre côté chez macron toujours
plus de l'europe qui n'a pas marché et
evennou et vous donc la volonté au
milieu des villas dans un instant on
accueille hedwige chevrillon a tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonjour hedwige chevrillon rappeler de
manière pour laurent wauquiez
bonjour beaucoup de questions là de
petites des précisions sur un ou deux
points vous avez déjà évoquée mais quand
même commencer par l'actualité sur le
plan économique et politique en
l'occurrence très fort c'est la
privatisation d'aéroports de paris dans
le cadre de la loi pacte qui a donc été
adopté alors à l'occasion ce vote on a
vu une espèce d'alliance un peu
improbable entre des républicains entre
des communistes des socialistes pour
demander un référendum d'initiative et
des centristes des référendums
d'initiative partagée
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes si opposés
à la privatisation d'un dp alors que
vous qui êtes président de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
vous êtes au sein du capital de da de
lyon-saint-exupéry l'aéroport de votre
région en l'occurrence qui a été
privatisé avec un consortium il ya vingt
six et oui à la région donc pourquoi ce
qui marche à lyon ne marcherait pas à
paris je vais vous répondre sur ce sujet
est d'ailleurs votre question a le
mérite de nous faire entrer directement
dedans c'est pas une question
idéologique c'est une pure question
totalement pragmatique il ya des
domaines où la privatisation marche et
même dans les aéroports il peut y avoir
des domaines vous en avez évoqué
certains kiev qui ont marché à l'exemple
de lyon mais ça marche à lyon pardon
mais vous auriez pu ensuite et un autre
nous mais ça marche t2 laissons-nous
quand même deux secondes pour quand même
se poser sur un sujet aussi important
toulouse à l'envers c'est un fiasco
privatisation gérée à l'époque par un
certain ministre de l'économie de
françois hollande qui s'appelait manuel
macro et en a même oublié qu emmanuel
macron a été ministre et conseiller de
françois hollande qui a été un fiasco
total rachetée par des actionnaires
chinois qui ont vidé la trésorerie est
parfait les investissements pourquoi
est-ce que ce dossier me gêne on a le
sentiment que le gouvernement l'a fait à
la va-vite bâclée et précipitamment
pourquoi ça s'est quand même temps qu'on
en parle et madame on va aller jusqu'au
bout et quand même vous le savez très
bien y compris des économistes
ultralibéraux disent attention le
dossier pas sérieux pourquoi il n'est
pas sérieux
parce que quand on le regarde qu'est ce
qu'on voit on voit que le fruit de la
privatisation risque de rapporter moins
à l'état que si jamais rester
actionnaire c'est à dire que le danger
c'est qu'en fait on vante juste les
bijoux de famille dans la précipitation
et pourquoi pas tout le monde l'a bien
compris c'est comme n'y a pas d'économie
sur la dépense publique
et comme le déficit du pays la voix est
améliorée vous avez lu les contre
arguments alors après avoir lobé droite
qui est de dire justement l'argent on va
récolter avec cette privatisation on va
être placé avoir un rendement qui sera
supérieur au dividende
adp qui sont vendues en région très bon
mais ferme l'homme chevrillon vous
n'allez pas vous même tomber là dedans
ça c'est du pur marketing politique
parce que si on nous dit on veut faire
un fonds d'innovation il suffit de
prendre les dividendes da dp est
désaffecté un fonds pour l'innovation
vers les 2 150 à 175 yens différence
annoncé jeudi un revirement c'est
justement bien notre problème c'est que
la grosse crainte qu'on a c'est qu'en
réalité on brade le patrimoine des
français est qu'on ait aucun bénéfice
allons jusqu'au bout de ce dossier
pourquoi est ce qui me préoccupe on peut
apprendre du passé
mais si on faisait les compressions
apprenez de ce que vous avez fait à lyon
m
et si on apprenait plus avec les mêmes
nous avons peut-être donc dans la cus
auriez peut-être pas contre un moment ou
un autre privatise adp mais peut-être
pas maintenant en soi des aéroports il
ya des aéroports privé qui marche très
bien
londres il ya des aéroports publics qui
marche très bien genève est un des
exemples des aéroports les plus
performants là c'est pas ça le problème
c'est pas la question de principe
la question qui pose problème c'est de
se dire y risque de brader les prix et
de se retrouver quelque chose qui nous
rapportera moins que si on était
propriétaire allons dans le détail l'un
ce qui est prévu c'est 70 ans et vous
prendre c'est servir en concession c'est
pas tout à fait sûrs d'être appréciez
vous le savez mais monsieur réunion vous
qui est une experte en la matière c'est
pas exactement une concession
c'est un dispositif qui est un peu plus
subtil de transmission avec ensuite
expropriations à la fin soyons vraiment
c'est prometteur
mais ce qui est prévu c'est la
pérennisation des autoroutes soixante
dix
vous pensez sérieusement que sur
soixante dix on est capable d'anticiper
regardez ce qui s'est passé pour les
autobus à célébrer les concessions oui
mais serait certes mais mains d'une
concession mais ça signifie qu'on peut
brader le patrimoine est au début les
autoroutes c'était une bonne affaire
parce que les taux d'intérêt étaient
élevés mais ensuite ça s'est avéré dans
le temps de venir une très mauvaise
affaire puisque les tonalités rock alice
a été vendu très cher ça évolue bien peu
aujourd'hui évidemment ça a été vendu en
apparence très cher et vous le savez
comme moi on s'est en réalité aperçu que
les torts et gagner beaucoup plus à
garder les autoroutes que ce qu'il a
fait donc moi qu'est ce que l'on vous
êtes opposés au retrait sans mal un
maintien tandis que sur ce dossier
on va trop vite c'est bâclé les
garanties ne sont pas sur la table et
donc le danger
on le comprend bien c'est qu'en réalité
on vende à tout prix à n'importe quel
prix juste pour éponger en apparence la
dette alors qu'on fait pas le vrai
travail qui est attendu baisser le
déficit et baisser la dépense publique
c'est vrai qu'on a compris juste
peut-être un mot il y avait une
polémique aussi vous permettez quand
même de rajouter un petit mot sur
seulement parce qu'il faut qu'on parle
des retraites
on a encore beaucoup de sujets là on
aura duré cinq minutes oui tant mieux
juste un point politique
vous l'avez vous même relevé
l'opposition à ce dossier de l'aéroport
vient de personnalités qui viennent
d'horizons très différents et compris
boris vallot qui a fait la privatisation
de toulouse lorsqu'il était à l'elysée
bien je vais vous dire ce que je trouve
je trouve que le gouvernement en
écoutant pas le fait que des voies
diverses venant du sens de la gauche de
la droite lui dise attention et en le
méprisant comme il le fait à tort
et au fond ce qui montre c'est que le
gouvernement et le pouvoir n'a pas tiré
les leçons du passé
qu'est ce que les français lui reprocher
au cours des deux ans nous écoutait pas
assez vous ne prenez pas suffisamment
compte les propositions qui si massa
pauline de madame rappelait elle était
notre invité la semaine dernière elle
disait moi je suis d'accord si la région
ile de france y participe
les départements et participent à cette
liste est sur la table c'est une façon
de le dire et pourquoi népal n'est-elle
pas écouté pourquoi est ce que les
propositions de bon sens portée par la
présidente de la région ile de france ne
sont pas écoutés qui savait bien d
opposition comptent pour vous il ya des
choses uniques alors c'est plus est le
plus petite polémique évidemment c'est
moi sur le fond à propos de la l'autre
privatisation qui est là la fdj l'année
a sion le jeu la française des jeux la
nomination de la femme du président du
groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale qui est une
personne que l'on connais
professionnellement qui est compétente
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
polémique qui est un peu machiste ou pas
ou quand on est une femme d'heure on n'a
pas le droit de la voir un job même ces
réunions je pense que ce débat n'a rien
à voir avec la question de savoir si on
est une femme ou un homme monsieur busin
marie agnès buzyn à renoncer à se
présenter au poste de l'inserm parce
qu'il a considéré que ça posait des
problèmes il était en passe pendant un
an et demi oui il avait été nommé avant
il a renoncé à se représenter
considérant que ça n'était pas
compatible
madame legendre devrait renoncer à ce
poste il ya beaucoup trop de soupçons
il ya beaucoup trop de zones d'ombré ce
qui s'est passé soyons là dorment pas
sur la nomination vous sur le choix
la précédente directrice de la
communication comme par hasard de la
française des jeux a relevé d'ailleurs
par vos collègues du monde à renoncer à
son poste en janvier
cette privatisation de la française des
jeux nettes acquises face à une
opposition parlement que par
l'implication très forte du groupe en
marche dont son mari à l'impact dans son
mari et le président et de façon très
étonnante on découvre il n'en a jamais
parlé dans l'hémicycle et il aurait dû
être transparent sur ce chiffre
on découvre que son épouse prend juste
avant le vote de la loi le poste de
directrice de la communication
je vous le dis ça n'est pas sain ça n'a
rien à voir avec la question de savoir
si c'est un homme ou une femme
ça n'a rien à voir avec la question de
sa compétence sacré justin soute sont
extrêmement lourds de conflit d'intérêt
et donc madame legendre devrait renoncer
à ce poste ça n'est pas bon pour la
transparence et ça n'est pas mon pour
l'exemplarité dont je vous rappelle que
théoriquement le président de la
république nous avait dit qu'il en
ferait sa marque de fabrique et au cours
des deux ans qui se sont accumulés on a
eu beaucoup trop d'illustration d'une
absence d'exemplarité
je considère donc je vous le redis que
madame le genre devraient renoncer à ce
poste pour que tous les soupçons soient
levés et un parent a très rapidement
juste sur les retraites
est ce que c'est la meilleure façon de
faire des économies en fait d'allonger
l'âge de départ à la retraite parce que
c'est sûr là on trouve une solution
toute trouvée
j'aime bien votre question c'est rare
qu'on appose comme ça vire
c'est très rare qu'on la pose comme ça
il est giflé maintenant du coup ça vaut
tu vois que ça maintenant je vais vous
répondre c'était précisément les chances
qu'on y apolline de malherbe
ce qui me gêne en france c'est que il ya
un certain nombre de réformes dont on
parle facilement mais qu'on ne s'attaque
pas aux problèmes structurels du poids
de l'état des collectivités locales de
la gestion administrative du pays de la
bureaucratie dans ma région quand j'ai
baissé les dépenses de fonctionnement ce
que j'ai cherché à faire c'est que faire
fonctionner la région au quotidien coûte
moins cher et chez d'accord avec vous
dans la proche qui en ce moment sur la
dépense publique ce qui est très gênant
c'est qu'il n'y a aucun effort qui est
fait en la matière au fond faire en
sorte qu'on soit capable de rendre le
même service mais plus efficacement dans
un chalet retraite
vous pensez que c'est effectivement une
des pistes de faire des économies alors
par exemple pour les retraites si on
applique votre principe est bien juste
la gestion de notre système de retraite
en france parce qu'on verse mais juste
la gestion administrative coûte 15 à 20%
de plus que tous les autres systèmes
européens et donc une bonne façon aussi
de l'aborder c'est de se dire est ce
qu'on est capable juste sur la gestion
administrative du système français de
retraite de faire des économies sur la
bureaucratie et ça c'est une bonne
question et elle est tellement rare dans
notre pays dernière question elle est
chauffée dernière question vous recevez
la police je vois laurent berger est
tout à leur petite question vous
rappeler devant cette fameuse réunion
devant les étudiants de m lyon vous
aviez dit à propos des syndicats les
syndicats cherchent bien moi à défendre
les intérêts de leurs adhérents qu'à
vivre des largesses de l'état et du
reste nous la région on verse un chèque
de 3 millions à la cgt est-ce que vous
maintenez cette phrase ou pas où c'était
plutôt une phrase dite un peu comme ça
ben non évidemment que je ne m'en tiens
parce que c'est la vérité
chaque année on en gros il ya même un
rapport qui a été rendu dessus et qu'on
a cherché à camoufler de monsieur
perruchot à l'époque le financement
public pour les syndicats ces 4
milliards d'euros là où tous les autres
syndicats européens sont financés à 80%
par les cotisations
oui je maintiens le fait de dire que
tout le monde doit faire des efforts les
élus comme les partenaires sociaux et
que de ce point de vue c'est même une
des propositions qu'on a mis sur la
table on pourrait réduire le financement
public des partenaires sociaux deux au
moins un milliard dont on en revient
donc à la baisse de la dépense publique
c'est beaucoup les chevrons merci
laurent vecchi d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes le président des
républicains dans un instant l'actualité
continue sur bfm